fette tor der fette torleute also ich
habe mir echt in dem kino gefragt wie
sie das genau umgesetzt haben ich fand
tatsächlich dass dieser vetter tor
einfach
hey leute es ist endlich da avenger
endgame visual effects breakdowns sind
da deswegen werde ich da heute drauf
reagieren und wir das ganze mal angucken
nur noch angucken wie avengers denn ohne
visual effects ausgesehen hatte will ich
wirklich mal gespannt dieses video
interview übrigens beute also wenn ihr
avengers entgehen und ich geguckt habe
dann decken jetzt mal wieder absolut
kommt wird alles im pc entstanden und
grinst natürlich die kameras sind hier
das gehört ich weiß ich genau wieso
eventuell und lief voll wasser oder sand
zu schützen auf jeden fall kassel sei es
ein riesen müllbeutel und gewickelt
haben geht jetzt schauen wir wirklich
auch herausgefunden wo ein bisschen erde
ist und da kann schon mal sein dass ein
aufgehebeltes und kann ich mir vorstelle
dass ich deswegen die müllbeutel darum
gespannt haben acht punkte machen das
ist nahe
ich habe übrigens der motion capturing
beziehungsweise peschl capturing
software entdeckt die absolut
geisteskranke sagte möglich da werden
auf jeden fall absolut gar videos aber
zu kommen leute da freue mich wirklich
darauf ganz so krass wie dem erwähnt ist
ein game ist natürlich nicht aber es
wird auf jeden fall ziemlich blass man
zieht er jetzt gerade die einzelnen
länder passes das heißt viele denken
vielleicht auch jemand 3d animiert
irgendetwas anders raus und dann ist das
video fertig nein so ist es nicht mal in
3d animiert etwas und hat dann viele
verschiedene einzelne durchgänge wo von
vielen verschiedenen unterteilen das 3d
renderings also man hat hier einmal das
3d modell ansicht weil so die dvs map
dann hat man verschiedene licht ebenen
wahrscheinlich haben die hier jedes
einzelne licht das in dreidimensionalen
raum existiert hat in der einzelnen
ebenen gehabt damit jedes licht noch mal
hinterher 1 und abstimmen können wir
haben hier nochmal global illumination
dass ich nicht das licht das direkt von
der lampe ins gesichtsfeld sondern das
licht was einfach von der lampe an der
wand bauens oder dann wieder an den
boden und dankbar die ersten die sich
kommt also diese
umgebungslicht was auf einen wirkt dann
hatte hier noch mal von rechts tradition
sehr sehr warm ist highlight gehabt und
dadurch dass man diese einzelnen ebene
eben extra macht kann man die alle
hinterher noch mal einzeln abstimmen was
viele von euch wahrscheinlich nicht
wussten hier mega spannend sehen wir
gerade dass er schauspieler fontanas
hier einfach so ein schild auf sein
das zeigt man sich einfach den anderen
schauspielern jeher zu dem fall
trainingstag oder robert downey junior
an wo er hingucken muss mal wenn er
jetzt weiß ich den echten schauspielern
sich gucken würde dann würde er tat als
irgendwie auf dem bau oder so deswegen
wirkt er da oben aufs schild und dann
sieht quasi hinterher so aus als würde
wirklich gucken obwohl er gar nicht da
ist okay die haben wir sogar so ein
chaos pappaufsteller darum gleich
natürlich auch hier mit dem hammer
faszinierend dass ich liebe ich weiß
nicht wieso wie gesagt leute ich liebe
diese klaren dass man sie heißen diese
frauen dinger weil das halt einmal
gerade gut dass sie den typ der mark
unangemeldeter aber es ist komplexer
systeme
[Musik]
okay wir haben sie den kollegen denn bei
der alt gemacht sehen wir jetzt ok und
die haben einfach die haben wirklich
tatsächlich schauspieler gesucht
sie haben ja also tatsächlich einen
alten schauspieler organisiert der
ungefähr aussieht wie chris evans dann
aussehen könnte wenn er 106 jahre
gealtert wäre
und dann haben sie sein gesicht drauf
gekriegt das ist einfach so krass wie
sie diesen chris evans ihren urlaub
gemacht haben
übrigens deswegen sage ich auch in jedem
video einfach zu dünn aus ich bin
eigentlich mindestens genauso passt wie
er mache ich mir einfach die mühe in
jedem video das ich dann immer so
aussieht wie der andere band gegeben was
auch ganz interessant ist ohren und
nasen wachsen bei einem menschen nämlich
ewig lang auch wenn zum beispiel die
körpergröße ja nicht mehr ewig wächst
deswegen haben die hier auch noch mal
was richtig krass es hier diese
nasenflügel und die ohrläppchen wie man
jetzt gerade sieht noch mal einfach
größer gemacht einfach weiß hat
realistisch ist weil wenn der halt dann
nochmal 100 jahre älter werden wird er
quasi nicht mehr wachsen seinen kopf her
nicht mehr größer aber seine ohren
wachsen immer noch und seine nasenflügel
wurde seine nase auch noch deswegen
geiles detail rechtsperson als vierte
tor der fette torleute also ich habe mir
echt in dem kino gefragt wie sie das
genau umgesetzt haben ich fand
tatsächlich dass dieser vetter tor
einfach nicht perfekt war weil sein
bauch der hat nicht so verzweifelt leute
also ich glaube so und so und wenn jetzt
eine echte wandhalter wenn man daran
geht dann schwappt also wirklich aber
tors waren für die wahrung bisschen fest
so als hätten diese weges und plastik
panzer herum gemacht deswegen gucken wir
mal wie das dann wirklich umgesetzt
haben hier der dicke tor
na endlich sie sagt natürlich politisch
korrekt gesagt nicht vetter tor sie sagt
and games soll okay also wieder einmal
für eine echte wahl hier müssen wir rom
schwaben also seine arme sind alle da
aber die ist echt krank holy [ __ ]
komplett also kein signal an diesen
dingen darf team yawara hinten dann doch
ein bisschen city hier sieht man dass
diese falten zusammengestutzt wurden am
pc aber prinzipiell ist sie eigentlich
fast komplett
ich war ein bisschen schade fand eine
million mal richtig geld in action sehen
und die frage gerade erzählt dass der
rocker ziemlich easy war weil sie dann
einfach von guns of the galaxy jobs dann
haben sie einfach das 3d modell von
wegen quasi abgenommen und hatten daher
relativ wenig arbeit
okay war bradley cooper also dem
schauspieler dann quasi ein waschbär
gemacht habe haben sie keine punkte
kraft gemacht wie die frau gerade
hintergrund erzählt ein paar weil die
gesichtszüge von dem was person
verschieden sind wie die von den
menschen dass es sich nicht gelohnt
hätte der mann trotz um die geste cool
aktion von eben natürlich gefilmt
während der die synchronisiert hat dann
wenn wir das möglichst realistisch in
diesen charakter umwandeln kann aber die
haben uns nicht so krass gemacht wie
beim zahnarzt dass wir gewalt punkte
gesetzt das an eins zu eins übertragen
haben am set hatten wir dann tatsächlich
ein jubel der dann den spielkreis als ob
geil
nice das ist einfach ein mensch der da
knie macht aber auch komplett sind da
sonst wissen die schauspieler nicht wo
sie sich bewegen sollen wir müssen die
kameramänner nicht okay wie setze ich
jetzt den frame das ist halt möglichst
gut einfach aussieht mit den typen dann
trennt kann dich einfach schlecht
vorstellen beim arbeiten deswegen
absolut als dass ich auf menschen haben
auch mega sinnvoll dass wir da keine
probleme sondern menschen dazu bewegen
kann und umlaufen dran aber das sind
diese dinge an die man einfach nicht
denkbar im film das der weg ist den man
auf den knien drin damit diesen anzug
den kennt vielleicht noch aus dem film
diesen nano anzug den hansi nicht wie
die anderen anzüge wirklich tragen
sondern der ist es einfach aus dem grund
weil sie es zeitlich nicht schnell genug
geschafft haben diesen anzugleichen
leben falls sie herzustellen und an dem
zu geben was natürlich theoretisch
realistischer gewesen wäre als die
sozial zu machen aber wie gesagt ja
derzeit natürlich komplett riehl ist bei
diesem film haben sie das einfach schon
mal mit diesem blauen anzügen hier
gefilmt und dann hinterher quasi diese
anderen anzüge drauf gesetzt was
natürlich echt echt stark gelungen ist
weil also hier wäre ich nie
draufgekommen nie welche draufgekommen
dass jedes mal wenn leute diesen an zu
den fünf tragen dass das ideal ist
was bei diesen helm auch mega geil ist
dass die ursprünglich nicht mal geplant
haben so ein heim zu machen der echt gut
reinpasst ursprünglich haben die nämlich
geplant so eine gabel zu machen wie bei
egal denn software galaxy auch quasi
dann über den kopf trug damit ja auch
ins weltall gehen können aber als die
bislang gemacht haben wir sind natürlich
aufgefallen hätte bruder das sieht ja
absolut schlecht aus und dann muss ich
noch zustimmen ich stelle mir vorher
durch den film gibt dann würde so
aussehen oder nein
gut das ist dann ja natürlich stark dass
es so gemacht damit dem helm aber er ist
auch krass dass die beim drehen noch
nicht mal wussten dass sie so einen
hellen drauf kriegen sondern die dachten
da womöglich die krieg gegen eine blase
über kopf oder sonstwas wasser
simulation sind für mich immer noch das
faszinierendste leute glauben dass das
einfach alles was sie dann daraus werde
ich das war's dann was er so ein
komplexes ding aber es sieht aber so aus
dass man sowas schon simulieren kann
leute das passt nämlich absolut komplett
das ist so geil mit diesen verschiedenen
ebenen auch und viele verschiedene
darstellungen von diesem wasser und
jetzt ist auch wirklich so so hätten in
den sieben sowas zu simulieren weil du
ja 1000 einzelne partikel simulieren
musst um diese bewegung dann auch
letztendlich zu kriegen um den eingriff
das monster möglichst realistisch
darzustellen haben sie natürlich da eine
person stoff bock hin gemacht den da so
ein typ im grünen anzug trägt richtig
richtig geil was ist das leider nein
okay die an den captain america
dupliziert greenscreen aber stark alles
andere ist 3d außer die beiden als die
das gefilmt haben die jede szene mit
chris evans gedreht außer wo man beide
auf einmal sieht der handel quasi in
body double drin gehabt damit die eben
wirklich eine richtige aktion haben dann
haben sie das gesicht von chris evert
auf das tube drückt zu das ist quasi
zweimal hatten
das ist dann können wir noch mal ganz
kurz
hahaha guckt euch jetzt mal die leute an
die fallen der da echt grund das ist ein
echter stuntman die da jetzt von der
fallen
hahaha schild also da bleibe ich lieber
bei visual effects wenn ich mich da
nicht auf die fresse lassen musstest du
mir das dann ganz recht alte oma in gott
ist das geil ich finde gerade kann sich
jetzt nicht so wichtig für den für die
serie aber die haben ja so eine gabel wo
die ihren körper draufhaben und alter
ist es heftig und zu drehen sie einfach
die leute leute gucken da haben wir ganz
oft einmal das ist unfassbar kannst dir
haben oben quasi ihr gewicht an dem sein
und hinten hat einer so ein lenkrad wo
man die quasi drehen kann und da vorne
an dem punkt wo das heil diese stange
berührt ist noch mal jemand der das
alles steuert also wird die quasi von
zwei leuten gesteuert die beiden extrem
nützlich im blaumann zu tun haben und
das ist wirklich sehr sehr geil gemacht
ganz schön heißt peter ratzer haben sie
eine erste rate genommen ist nichts
haben sie wirklich eine ratte gehabt das
team war geisteskrank fand den film auch
richtig weiß ich auch was hat euch
gefallen ich suche aktion übrigens man
jemanden der mir beim schneiden
außerhalb also wenn ihr schneiden könnte
über 16 zeit und auch geld verdienen
möchte meine wie die umschreibung
bestehende niemand und ein kleiner text
was sie alles beachten muss trainer
bewerbung und dann finde ich super geil
wenn wir jemand anschneiden aushalten
könnte hätte ich bock drauf wenn die
schneiden werden möchte dann schaut auch
in die video beschreibungen da ist mein
schnittkurs in köln abdecken und wenn
ich auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
dann kann ich mich auf ihn zugegangen
folgen bilder und abonniert mich auf
jeden fall auf youtube dann sehen wir
nicht nur nächste mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]